okay good morning checking in I'm in my
morning uniform which is my green comfy
which I actually just
washed which is amazing I hardly wash
this thing but I wear it all the
time sorry just checking to see how my
stomach is doing what we do all day long
it's just like little body checks we are
oh it's upside down we're putting
together some liquid IV for herself it's
Monday it's Monday morning every morning
we give ourselves a dope girl bottle of
liquid IV and some coffee if we're
filling up to it
tada crystals haven't dissolved that's
fun nice and gritty tasting and a little
bit of coffee I've noticed that after
infusions for the first like week or so
my body doesn't want coffee which is
devastating it deems it gross so sad cuz
I love coffee in the morning as a ritual
and as caffeine now finally I'm about
almost 2 weeks out from infusions and my
body wants coffee in the morning and
that's very exciting 9:46 a.m. today
we'll see how the vlogging goes this
week I've already forgotten to do it all
last week so I picked up the camera
today as a way to just get it going
today we are going to get an
echocardiogram is that how you say echo
cardiogram basically I have to get my
heart checked because these medications
can mess with your heart I have to go
get a little heart check to make sure
this thing is pumping correctly and it's
really no big deal it's like 45 minutes
however it is it's just like this whole
thing is very awkward as someone who's
pretty reserved in their body naturally
it really forces you to shed all of
those walls and just like give your body
over to science basically go into a room
strip off from the waist up and you just
lay on a table while they measure your
heart for like a half hour to 45 minutes
so we're going to go get half naked in a
room with a stranger to make sure that
I'm surviving well through this process
ooh big Monday what else is there to
report just a lot of fatigue and a lot
of gut stuff this time around my stomach
has not settled for weeks now so we're
still trying to eat a very boring bland
diet which is so boring and so Bland but
it's for the betterment of our body
we've already eaten an oatmeal and a
banana this morning life is wild over
here oh look how bright lit up by my
Dashboard Light anyone hungry I got some
meatloaf we are in the parking lot of C
sin and we are going to go get an echo
cardiogram going to say Echo cardigan
which sounds like a Taylor Swift song
we're going to go take our shirt off
girls gone wild and get our heart
checked girls gone healthy we're a
little early so we can take our time
which is great this is a new era of my
life too where um I've been way oh
there's someone walking you're just a
normal adult woman vlogging in her car
which is pretty normal these days I am a
bit in a new era of my life where I'm
early for things occasionally that's
never happened for years and years I was
always late and running high anxiety of
being late constantly just putting
around panicking before I had to go
somewhere and now I'm early so I can
just sort of
like
[Music]
sit
don't be afraid of wet moist dirty
things don't be afraid to get your hands
dirty don't be afraid to have a dirty
mind don't be afraid to have lascivious
thoughts don't be afraid to have obscene
thoughts don't be afraid of things that
are future oriented and don't be afraid
of
spontaneity spontaneity doesn't mean
being Reckless it is Tuesday you know
what that means we sit in our car H in
the parking lot getting ready to go into
therapy because we got here early I
don't really have anything else to say
it's a very full parking lot and people
are driving around looking for a spot
and I don't want to give them the
illusion that I'm leaving no no I just
got here a little early cuz I'm doing a
Great era of arriving early to
appointments but I'm still too shy to
just go sit around in the waiting room
so instead I'll wait in my car little by
little but otherwise I'm doing well
today feeling a little bit better I have
had I'll tell you diarrhea like crazy
for the last 2 weeks all day every day
finally I told my doctor cuz I was like
this can't be normal I understand
there's diarrhea associated with cancer
but this is excessive and now I have to
take two em modium every 2 hours today
block it up okay they're looking for
spots I got to go oh post therapy no
tears today still good session but no
crying my therapy has variety hello it's
later in the evening on Tuesday mayry
and I just finished podcasting for the
week over Zoom it was delightful and
also we had maybe one of the more more
in-depth
conversations we've ever had on the
podcast a conversation about modern
feminism and our lives as it correlates
that said um I turned this on cuz I
wanted to show you something as you can
see we readed our kitchen cabinets I
haven't done a full like reveal of it
cuz I haven't done a cooking video but
do you want a little reveal here's a
little reveal it's a mess hell big it's
a mess look we did these cabinets and
then the kitchen's a mess any home
person would be so disappointed that the
kitchen's a mess but really cool stuff
no the thing I wanted to show you was
this look at this I got from Etsy look
at this beautiful thing I couldn't
figure out what I wanted over here on
the table and then I went on Etsy and
found this thing called a flower bar and
it comes with all these dry flowers and
this little peg board and you just put
them in there this is absolutely
something you could probably make pretty
easily yourself but I did didn't I paid
someone else who made it and then they
shipped it to me and then I got to poke
all the little flowers in in my own
order and make it feel like I did it all
myself I love it look how cute that is
my little brother is coming later in the
week so we got to get the house in order
everything outside is being like cleaned
and figured out um cuz I want to impress
him he's grown into quite an amazing
interior designer in his new place and I
want to impress him I'm older but I have
a constant need to prove that I'm better
oh that's that's the other thing I just
ordered some pizza and some macaroni and
cheese because here let's sit down and
talk about this I talked about it on the
podcast but I'll talk about it here give
you a little health update I'm doing a
lot better I'm feeling a lot better I
sound I think like I'm feeling better
and that's truth I am feeling a little
bit better and it's also misleading
because they get you to a point where
you feel better and you forget about all
the bad and then they go come on in
let's put you full of some secret
poisons and then we'll just you get out
of here again feeling just more fatigued
this time around and then I've had a ton
of diarrhea that's the other side of it
I'm just every day I emailed my doctor
about it and he said take two em modium
every 2 hours and that should fix it and
that seems like a lot of em modium in a
little bit of time and so far it's going
really well and with that I'm going to
have a gluttonous dinner because I think
I've taken enough am modium that it
shouldn't hurt me at least that's the
math I'm doing in my head about it
fullon ramble vomiting it at you
vomiting I have not done with all these
side effects and
that that makes me feel like I can
handle all the other ones the vomiting
still but I've been puking from a
different hole um okay that's the update
I got some beautiful flowers and I've
been having constant
diarrhea good morning I just wanted to
show you these new amazing Crocs that my
friend Sarah WID gifted me can you see
can you see it can you see it can you
see it hello I'm in my own car again
isn't that what vlogging is these days
just people in their cars trying to shut
out the rest of the world I just got off
the phone with my brother I'm so excited
he's coming into town tomorrow I'm going
to go to Trader Joe's to try and get
some snacks and stuff to stock up for
his visit I haven't been to Trader Joe's
in years but I keep seeing Tik toks of
people making food from Trader Joe's and
it looks so good so I'm going to go to
Trader Joe's why have I not gone to
Trader Joe's in years is because it's
too charismatic there people are too
forthright with their RZ employees are
too extroverted they see me in a
shopping environment in which I often
don't want to be seen I'd like to be
invisible and their whole purpose is to
make you visible as a customer and that
is very off-putting to me but these Tik
toks look so good I know they got a lot
of great there and I've just been not
allowing myself to experience it fully
out of fear so we're going to face a
stupid fear right now we're going to go
to Trader Joe's and shop
around God right here that place was
crazy every aisle was full of employees
making sure that every single item on
the Shelf was perfectly aligned everyone
was blocking everything and I I could I
I I panicked and I bought a ton of [__]
I don't know what it is I don't know
what goes together Trader Joe's is not
meant for browsing it is meant for
people that know where they're going are
getting in and getting out and know what
they're getting and I was not any of
those things I wanted to look around
with an open mind I was like a salmon
swimming upstream and I just like
chaotically put my limbs out and grabbed
whatever was available to me and I got
miso paste and some candy among many
other items I got some flowers last
minute snag some flowers and some
espresso chocolate beans we need a
second to gather ourselves that was um
quite a stressful experience I think I'm
more of a Ralph's girl I think I prefer
Ralph to Joe Ralph seems like he doesn't
give sh he just throws a bunch of in the
a room and says good luck take your time
hello it's Thursday another day another
psyching myself up to go out to run a
public errand where all my introverts
still feeling residual side effects of
the pandemic at hey this time the errand
is a little different mry Hart turns 40
years old tomorrow incredible mayry Hart
is also so extremely interested in wine
I'm going to try and get her a really
nice bottle of red wine I know nothing
about wine that requires me talking to
someone at a wine shop and asking them
to recommend something I have another
gift for her that's absolutely chaotic
and it's being made and I thought I
expedited it but I didn't so that might
get here in a few weeks and that one is
a real wild card it's not something she
needs or knows that she wants but we'll
see when it gets to that one's a little
bit more creative so we're going to in
the meantime get her a really nice
bottle of wine and then we're going to
go to Target and we're going to look for
board games because my little brother
gets into town later tonight but I
probably won't see him till tomorrow
because I get sleepy early these days I
was getting sleepy earlier before these
days started but now it's I'm in bed by
like
8:00 humble brag guys wine shopping
total success the guy that was in that
wine shop easy peasy I didn't have to
use any of my rehearse conversation and
he helped me find I think something
perfect for
mamory look how big this botle one
ideal once he showed me the novelty size
wine we were all in success now let's go
find board games successful Target visit
we got Katan we got another game we got
pumpkin scentered candles and then we
got
tired so we came back and we are in bed
I lay in bed for a couple hours and see
where the day takes us which might be to
more bed here's the problem I got really
tired when I was shopping at Target so I
was like I'm going to come home and take
take a nap saw that last night I put out
espresso bean chocolates in a little
dish cuz Elliot had a friend coming over
and I was trying to be like Hostess cute
like look our house just naturally has
like some candies and dishes around just
in case oh so I came home and I start
gobbling all the espresso with
chocolates my brain's like Bing and I'm
in bed with my body tired and my brain
Bing little unconscious self-sabotaging
ways but we'll be gentle on ourselves
body tired brain Bing hello vlog I just
took a shower which was lovely we
haven't had hot water for over a week
and we got our hot water tank fixed
yesterday also my little brother's in
town and I took him to one of the
hottest spots here in Los Angeles last
night the Cheesecake Factory at the
Americana elegant refined dining
experience on a Friday night I didn't
Vlog any of it because I wanted to spend
time with my family and not be a [__]
weirdo today is now Saturday and I slept
really poorly last night and I woke up
feeling pretty icky so so my little
brother I think might come over call him
I don't know why I don't call him Tim
you know Tim Tim might come over and I
think we might just chill on the couch
and watch TV today just like we used to
do when we were kids on Saturdays oh man
it is disappointing next Wednesday I get
my third round of chemo which is
incredible that that's gone so fast I
was feeling like better and better and
better every day and then yesterday I
woke up a little wonky and today I woke
up a little wonky and I think just like
pushing myself maybe a little bit more
than I should but look at this cute
thing I got look at that it's a glass
bag and you put candy in it how [__]
cute is that hey look who's here Tim's
here guess what Tim brought with him for
a day of
nesting uh a Nintendo 64 that we grew up
with and we already played some uh
Pokemon Stadium Sushi go round Sushi go
round best great game ever created
greatest game ever created created he's
introducing me to a show called siren
survive the island which is insane
already and we're eating popcorn it's
3:30 on a Saturday afternoon and we're
fully nesting successful visit so
far we're here we're in Palm Springs
bringing the brother to see the highball
house I didn't piss my pants I just have
sweated between my legs oh
cute yeah hi
[Music]
house uh-oh what's happening here I'm
cleaning he's cleaning because he's been
making
soup oh my God how what a sweetie making
me soup good morning we're down here in
the womb room in Palm Springs wonder why
I call it the womb room just [__]
look at it down here with my brothers
and Elliot to have a nice couple days
and it's really nice except I feel kind
of crummy my stomach isn't great here's
my collection of autra mons and I have a
delicious breakfast that Elliot just
brought me of toast and bananas so
having fun just like thought I might
feel a little bit better but I got to
listen to my body so we're going to eat
really boring stuff and lay down Palm
Springs is a perfect place for just
laying
down
[Music]
goodbye we just dropped him off at the
Palm Springs Airport look at it so cool
hello I've decided I'm going to do some
holiday decorating and I bought this off
of westelm yeah it looks like a cartoon
emo octopus but it's a big old spider
and I think it's sweet and hilarious but
uh update we just drove back up from
Palm Springs this morning dropped my
little brother off at the airport it was
very emotional it was so nice to see him
hold on I've had a very very emotional
day today I've been crying all day today
I think it was that it was so nice to
see my family my step brother came down
who lives out here in Los Angeles but to
spend time with him and Tim in Long
chunks of time which just so nice and it
was also like very confronting too
because I
felt sick like I couldn't really keep up
with them and we weren't doing anything
like that crazy just hang out and I felt
very tired and so it was like the first
time I felt very confronted of feeling
like very sick around people that are
not sick want to entertain and host and
the urge to want to do all these things
that I just I can't really do right now
I started throwing a bit of like a pity
party for myself I also had therapy
today too it's Tuesday guys also my
stomach wasn't feeling well like you've
heard this whole week I finally did the
BRAT diet thing and it really worked and
so I'm sticking to that but it's just
hard to get calories which is a little
stressful and now it's the night before
we go to round three of chemo which is
amazing cuz that marks the halfway point
and it is starting to get tough
emotionally yeah like I feel weak I feel
tired but I don't want to let myself
wallow in like the negatives instead I
want to recognize that this is like
because we're doing it because we're
killing cancer this thing is temporary
and this is part of the process this is
what I didn't sign up for it's also a
lot cuz tomorrow is my birthday if you
know me you know I like to run out of
town on my birthday and not receive a
lot of that attention I don't know why
well I do a little bit I talked about in
therapy today of receiving that kind of
attention makes me uncomfortable and man
the universe is really making me work
through [__] which is kind of cool but
uncomfortable that's really what it is I
feel uncomfortable more than I feel
comfortable these days and I guess
that's the [__] of sickness and that is
the mental game that you have to manage
after all these years of trying to like
run away every birthday the universe is
like no you're going to sit down on your
birthday and in fact we're going to um
plug you in to some stuff so you really
cannot leave and we'll have to be around
people who will know it's your birthday
and you will have to sit there not for
like a few minutes no for hours I don't
know there's a lot of extra attention
this year all of that is what I'm
working on dealing with sorry I
shouldn't say sorry that's stupid so is
that I don't want to sit here and cry
but it has felt like a lot the last
couple days and I guess maybe the
highlight of it being my birthday just
like puts this extra Spotlight on it cuz
I feel like I'm starting to have to
really process to deal with a lot of the
side effects some days it's totally fine
and then some days it's this week I've
been really extra emotional about it
from seeing my family knowing that they
see me looking sick and looking sick I
think is the most confronting I've spent
so many years editing and crafting the
way that I appear to people on little
videos and off and so when that's out of
your control you feel out of control
it's been nice to cry through it though
today a different version of me would
really really hold it in waves all
emotional waves the good stuff is that
I'm going to be 38 tomorrow and we will
be halfway or starting the halfway point
of uh the chemo experience I also have
that steroid in me that I have to take
the day before my chemo sessions and
that always makes me feel very like this
so when I'm feeling like this and also
emotional it feels very like spiraling
suddenly so I have to breathe but I just
wanted to update you cuz I want to
update you on stuff that's going on and
also maintain some level of privacy but
I don't want to give you the illusion
that everything is so fine and good and
manageable all the time sometimes it's
really emotional that's okay it's just
uncomfortable good morning it's time for
chemo day three I'm eating a sensible
banana I'm waiting on a piece of toast
and we're making some coffee for Elliot
feeling a lot better today bowels are
feeling better today that's a game
changer let's go have one of the
weirdest birthdays of my adult life oh
and I said this on the podcast before
but I bought crumble cookies to give the
nurses today and I'm very nervous about
it but we're going to do it we're
meeting with the oncologist today oh
added activity today Us in the restroom
again before we start getting all the
you're out doctor said my blood counts
look good great birthday
news it begins it is
[Music]
cold uh-oh I didn't know this was
happening look at this man being cute oh
my
god oh boy look what this boy just said
up my
God uhoh got himself a little birthday
treat today too happy birthday thank you
yay round three is over slash it has
begun woo woo and now I'm going to eat
some french fries cuz I've earned it
gentle a gentle amount of french
fries oh my God this oh my God what you
know making a lemonade out of no as my
cold cap just slays behind you like it's
died of overworking today and look we
got crumble cookies deliver from Nathan
and Tyler it's so sweet and oh my god
what the hell we've tried one of these
before and they're like so scary they're
insane this is so fun but that smells
really good oh
sh oh my God oh my God I forgot how
stupid and insane it was there's so much
smoke in the
kitchen
got them all she still got lung capacity
killing it good morning it is Thursday
after infusion day three feel pretty
good today we're going to go back for
hydration today but it was a really
great and exhausting day yesterday there
were so many beautiful birthday messages
thank you to everyone and Elliot made it
a really sweet day even though it was a
really strange day I think I'm really
tired from all that so today let's go
get hydration I got a needle in my arm
from yesterday so weird this whole
thing's so weird we are now officially
halfway and we start counting down the
infusions versus counting up how cool it
feels like starting was so long ago and
yesterday we're in hydration we decided
to wear a hat today pretty big day this
one came with me this week pretty big
day no no photo back from hydration
looking like a latch key kid we just
gave this little thing a bath with our
last little bit of energy and now we're
making rice and we're going to relax
probably sleep this Begins the fatigue
onset and whatever other side effects
await me in this round three of
chemotherapy treatment so I'm going to
go into my Hobbit Hole of health and
nourishment and I will see you next
video thanks for being here